hello everyone and welcome to one of the
most exciting thrillers in chess history
now again Kasparov gave an interview for
The New Yorker I think it was about two
weeks ago the interview is about four of
his most memorable moments over the
chessboard I will put a link to the
entire interview in the description
below so you can check it out but I
thought it was it had some video making
potentials so I decided to make four
videos about four of these different
memorable moments so this is a memorable
moment number one and it's his famous
match against Anatoly Karpov as you all
know Garry Kasparov won the World Chess
Championship in 1985 he took it from
Anatoly Karpov and this is their 1987
rematch in Seville and this is game 24
so this is the final game of the match
and as you can see in the quote about
the board Kasparov says Caixa the
goddess of chess had punished me for my
conservative play for betraying my
nature and this is him talking about the
previous game game 23 I work as part of
as he explains that made one of the
greatest blunders of his life and
suffered a case of complete chess
blindness so this is game 24 he has the
white pieces and if he wants to win this
game he has to he has to do something
for her because for the past 23 games
the result is still in karpova's favor
so definitely you know requiring nerves
nerves of steel would be an
understatement here and as Perot also
says the last person who managed to win
the last game of the championship to
retain the title was actually Emmanuel
Lasker in 1910 when he was playing
against college life there and she left
her had a you know a reasonable position
and then all of a sudden she like that
just started playing aggressively and in
the end Alaska managed to defend and won
that game why he started to play
aggressively that's a you know people
don't know and some historians are even
considering that maybe a draw wasn't
enough for Elektra to win the title
maybe he had to actually had a positive
score or something and but okay let's
get back to this game so as part of in
this game opens with c4 and
as Kasparov says to win this game I had
to I had to try something new I had to
try something not only that I would be
comfortable comfortable with but also
something that I knew a karpova would be
uncomfortable uncomfortable with so
Kasparov said in this game I decided to
play against Karpov like Karpov so
casparo opens with C for the English
opening we have e 6 d AG in court
defense Knight to f3 Knight to f6 G 3 we
have D 5 and now B 3 here you can see
that Kasparov is ready to be in shadow
both of his bishops Bishop to e7 by
Karpov and here
Kasparov could have seized some space in
the center by actually pushing D for
let's say Bishop b2 c5 now and after e3
Knight to c6 that point is staying on d4
so it's definitely a good position for
black but instead as he knew that
Kasparov prepared for this game he
played Bishop to e7 Bishop to g2 we have
castles castles and now b6 as park our
Pope wants the play Bishop to b7 to
oppose Kasparov strong bishop and g2 so
the ship to be 2 we have Bishop to be 7
and now III Knight B to d7 Knight to c3
and Knight to e4 here cuz para carful
offers some exchanges in the center and
Kasparov isn't interested because para
ver declines the trade plays Knight to
e2 and here we have a 5 d 3 and now
Bishop to f6 Karpov finds a way to
exchange pieces as now if you capture
the night then Bishop captures Bishop on
b2 so Queen to c2 defending the bishop
on b2 and now Bishop captures Queen
captures and Knight comes to d6 now and
if you look at this position I mean
you're playing against Karpov look at
all the squares his Knights are covering
in the center this is this is pretty
terrible this is some Sun control and
you have to win this game so far I mean
your position is ok but it's not so it's
not looking like you're gonna win this
game
cuz power play the C capture Sun b5 we
have Bishop captures on d5 and now d4
see [ __ ] by Karpov rook to d1 roped the
c8 and now Knight to f4 Bishop captures
an f3 Bishop captures and now Queen to
e7 developing the Queen also ready to
develop the other route rook the c1 by
Kasparov and now rook F to e 8 by Karpov
and now both players have mobilized all
of their pieces and still the position
is roughly equal how is part of gonna
win this and retain his title well we'll
just have to watch and see he played the
D captures on c5 Knight captures on c5
and now he pushed before he wants to
destroy this connected pawn chain Karpov
has on the Queen side ache after some
before Queen captures on b4 and now
Queen to a7 both players now have a nice
pawn on the Queen side Karpov
immediately placed Queen to be a queen
to a7 going for the a to pawn we have a
three the queen is now defending the
pawn and nice to f5 rook to be one
threatening to capture the rock on e8
and then capture the pawn on d6 so we
had rook captures rook captures and now
Queen to c7 here Sparrow plays Knight to
d3 what was the idea here a carpel
definitely can exchange here and it
would be it would be probably sorry it
would be in his favour to exchange this
night but first he decided to play h6 he
won't he wants to create some breathing
space for the King so there won't be any
back back rank complications later
so h6 and here coz power plays rook to
see one now pinning that night we have
Knight to e7 and queen to b5 now
Knights back to f5 as now Karpov wants
to again play Knight to d6 what a tempo
and caused part of his Queen cause power
plays a 4 and now Knight to d6 Queen
back to be 1 and now Queen to a7 again
and this is a this is the crucial moment
of the game Karpov plays Queen to a7
there's a double attack on the a4 pawn
and
as part of has to do something there
really it's it's a hard decision to make
and here Kasparov played Knight to e5 he
offers the pawn on f4 of course you
can't capture with the Queen because
queen captures and b6 but you can
capture with the night and here maybe
just like maybe just like in the
collector game against the manual ask
her Karpov could have completely ignored
this he could have just moved the rock
rock f8 rook e8 but he actually decided
to play Knight captures on a4 III don't
think Karpov actually wanted to go for a
win here I just think he thought that he
has the time to grab it and then go back
with the night and that it will be
easier for him to draw the game but ok
Karpov plate and Knight captures on a4
here we have rook captures on c8 we had
Knight captures on c8 and this is
another critical moment of the game here
as part of hasn't calculated everything
but something something very weird
happened here the the arbiter that was
you know watching the game he tapped
Kasparov on the back and he said Mr
Prospero you have to write down the
moves because Kasparov was so deep in
thought he forgot to write down his
previous two moves so you know and when
you're calculating variations in chess
you don't want anyone distracting you so
I mean you're calculating a variation
here that will either we knew the world
change championship or it won't so any
distractions are not welcome but ok that
did happen and here Kasparov played
Queen to d1 and the Queen to d1 is a is
a good move but he actually had a
winning move this is something Kasparov
felt when he sacrificed the pawn but he
didn't find it now whether he would find
it if the arbiter didn't tap him on the
back that's a different question but the
move he missed because I will explain
what he played Queen d1 but the move he
missed was actually Queen to b5 keeping
an eye on this night on a4 also
threatening Queen to e8 check picking up
the night and also the Queen from EA
twould be controlling f7 square and
Knight is ready to capture on f7
so here king 2h7 not allowing this check
but Queen to e8 nevertheless now Knight
to d6 attacking the Queen and also
defending the f7 pawn queen to e8 and
this Queen to e8 this is the move
Kasparov probably missed when he was
when he was calculating the Queen to b5
move because now the Queen is attacking
the knight at the black queen there is
no square from where the black Queen can
defend the night and here if you play it
Knight to a5 or something to defend the
night it's all over Knight to c6
attacking the Queen and the knight is
protected by the bishop on f3 Queen has
to move and now comes g4 and black loses
a piece if you move the piece then comes
Bishop check 96 and now Knight to e7
will discover the attack on the Queen
and also there is a threat of Queen -
Queen to g8 checkmate
so when you play something like h5 you
don't even have to take the Queen it's a
force checkmate Bishop captures pawn
captures and now Queen here King here
and f4 and there is no defense either
against the g5 checkmate or Queen to h8
checkmate so this is the idea power of
mist after this Knight captures on c8 he
didn't find Queen to b5 rather he played
Queen to d1 but he thought this comes
with the same idea he's still eyeing the
night on a4 he's still threatening rook
to d8 would check winning the night but
there is a difference now it's Queen to
d8 and it's not Queen to e8 so this
gives carp of a great opportunity to
defend but unfortunately for Karpov here
Karpov misses the best defensive move
and I will show you the move but only
after I show you the game so this is
move 33 and here Karpov played Knight to
e7 and that best defensive move that
Karpov didn't find Kasparov didn't see
it during the game they found it only
after the game when they analyzed it so
Queen to d8 check King h7 and now Knight
captures on f7 because part of grabs
upon we have Knight to g6 guarding the H
H square and now Queen to e8 we have
Queen to e7 offering a trade of Queens
so either you trade Queens or the Queen
moves and then card for grabs tonight so
Kasparov plays Queen captures on a4 we
have Queen captures on f7 and now Bishop
to e4 pinning that night and improving
the position of the bishop as it was
attacked on f3 so King to g8 on pinning
and now Queen to b5 attacking the b6
pawn there's no way to defend it if you
move the Queen Queen then Kasparov will
grab the knight on g6 so night to f8 and
now comes Queen captures on b6 and this
is move 40 the game was adjourned in
this position so it will be continued
tomorrow and you know those were the
good old days when you could continue
games there were no engines to help you
and Kasparov spend the entire night
trying to find any winning ideas here
but he just couldn't so he does have a
better position and as Kasparov says he
can play this position forever because
black doesn't have any chances it's
either he will win or or it will be a
draw but because only white can play for
a win here but another interesting thing
as you'll see in the in the interview if
you check it out in the description when
Kasparov came the next day to the chess
game and they were about to continue
this game he came a bit early and when
he saw Karpov approaching the stage he
saw on Karpov face and in his body
language that because that Karpov
actually thought that he couldn't defend
this position against Kasparov and the
Kasparov says it was actually in that
moment that he knew that he had winning
chances
so here Queen to f6 by Karpov Queen to
b5 we have Queen to e7 and King to g2 as
power of says maybe some of these moves
are meaningless but you know we don't
have an infinite time to try and find a
move and another thing is it gives
Karpov a chance to blunder
so here already g6 is played and g6 is
an inaccuracy you don't want to touch
any of the pawns the pawns are nicely on
dark squares you just want to play
something like tonight d7 right back to
f8 simply keep the position as it is
even if because
probably something like this would be
one to eight to to try and pin at this
point and maybe push f4 f5 Karpov can
always simply move King h8 so here
Karpov played g6 Kasparov played Queen
to a5 again we have Queen to g7 Queen
back to c5 Queen to f7 and now Kasparov
pushed h4 and this is the magical
moments in the game where Karpov pushes
age 5 and when Kasparov saw h5 he knew
that he was gonna that I mean if he's
not gonna win this game after age 5 then
he doesn't deserve to be world champion
because now as he says it the pawn
structure is fixed and he can exchange
Queens and this endgame
Bishop against Knight being upon up is
winning for white so Queen to a5 c6 we
have Queen to e7 Bishop to d3 now Queen
back to f7 Queen to d6 now a Karpov
doesn't really have anything to do here
he's just repeating moves and he has to
see if Casper will think of something
King to g7 we have E for now King to g8
Bishop to c4 King to g7 25 check King
moves now Queen back to d6 King back to
g7 Bishop to b5 King to g8 Bishop to c6
Queen to a7 now and here Queen to b4
Queen back to c7 Queen to b7 now Sparrow
offers the trade of Queens Queen to d8
and now comes G 5 we have Queen to a5
Bishop to eh and this is that this is
that very nice moment we have Queen to
c5 and now Queen to f7 check King to h8
and now Bishop to a for Queen to d5
check King goes to h2 Queen to c5 Bishop
to b3
we have Queen to c8 Bishop to d1 now
Queen to c5 and King to g2 and para says
that after he played Queen to g2 that he
felt that he was gonna win this game
the like in another 10 moves because the
plan is relatively clear but he didn't
even have to because it was actually in
this position
that Karpov resigned at the game the
score was 12 12 to 12 in the second
world chess championship rematch and has
power retained his title
why did Carper resign here because now
let's say Queen d5 check now you play
Bishop f3 Queen moves now I have Bishop
to e4 going for the g6 pawn Queen to b4
attacking the bishop now King to h2 not
allowing this to be captured with check
now Queen captures then Queen captures
night here this will be winning so let's
say well okay let's show it if Queen
captures then Queen captures here and
after King moves then Queen f7 check
King h8 and now Queen captures on e6
this has been two pawns up and like it
doesn't have any counter play so after
King to h2 let's say maybe even Queen c5
but now comes King h3 Queen before back
and now f3 you don't want to grab that
g6 pawn just yet Queen to c5 now Bishop
captures on g6 knife captures Queen
captures and after Queen captures on e5
Queen age sex check King to g8 and now
Queen to g5 check and now you see that
the Kasparov forces a trade of Queens
being upon up this is completely winning
Queen catch Queen g7 or Queen captures
it's all the same Queen character skin
captures and now after g4 and a couple
of more moves you can see that this is
this is the D ending result and this
will be completely winning so yeah after
King to g2 carpet resign the game and
you know it's a very very important
moment in chess history yeah I forgot to
show you this is this is a photo of them
from this game yeah I took it from this
article from The New Yorker as you can
see here you know quite intensive both
of them young both of them eager eager
to play good chess and to become the
world champion and another thing I have
for you is this this is their overall
lifetime record in classical games as
you can see as part of beat em Polycarp
of 2821 so far
1:28 against Karpov 21 and they drew a
hundred and twenty-one times so as you
can see that that's a pretty big rivalry
that's lasted for like for like forever
and I don't think there's there's been a
rivalry like that ever in chess history
so both of them played amazingly and it
was always by like this that Kasparov
managed to gain the title and to retain
it so yeah that's it that's the first
part of memorable moments from the video
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Adam lever and Joseph Weinstein
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it
I'll probably make more videos like this
you know part 2 3 & 4 but we'll see so
yeah as usual you can check too on my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon